um
there's just some other things that i
was just thinking about that my mind
always goes during the podcast or
whenever i'm doing a video with pearl
but i think it's a very
um
important conversation to have
amongst adults amongst just people in
general
and from different backgrounds whether
you're in the church out of the church
whether you're in school out of school
whatever it is i think it's a very very
important conversation
i'd like to know
based on everything that's gone on
regardless of your beliefs and how you
feel about it
going back to almost like the original
point is
how do you view corn now do you think
it's
beneficial for relationships and dating
i don't i don't think it's beneficial
for relationships in dayton
i actually personally think
that you should make your own corn
hmm
i make my own
watch it back
like i did that thing
that was me okay that was me so i don't
need to like
generally watch other people do you know
i mean i think you can be excited by sex
you know
without
you know going down that corn rabbit
hole because like you said like just to
get that dopamine response you're gonna
be wanting something better or more
taboo or more crazier and and it's just
like where does it end
yeah um
i don't know i've never really thought
corn was good for people so
i don't know i just i i agree i think
for something that is so
addictive and so
powerful and powerful
it can't be good for you and be free um
i think the concept of it is very sick
to be fair but it's normalized but if in
the reality of it is is sick it's
perverted because
essentially i'm watching you to have sex
and i'm getting off on it yeah
it's that's a bizarre thing that that's
normal
you know um
yeah i i'm definitely against it in a
relationship not even in the
relationship just in general because
even if you're in a relationship
whatever you've watched when you consume
through corn when you get a relationship
you want to try everything
you know i mean you you get like you
take an innocent girl
and by the time that relationship is
done she's like one girl she's going to
have the deepest throw ever and that's
going to be a new norm you know what i
mean but before you and before you
experiencing that and passing it on to
her
to her sex is just normal yeah i mean so
yeah
it's it's definitely um
more negative than positive yeah i think
it's just bad in general i think um the
negative connotations that come with it
whether it's to do with like the
opposite of seeming retention
or just the
views that you have of women yes yes the
relationships that you you've kind of
festered in your mind
that aren't real life situations 100 can
have so many bad connotations to your
future relationships yeah yeah it's just
bad um
i think there's a time and a place
for it like high days holidays
spare of the moment maybe to rekindle to
just come together again corn or sex
corn all right okay to you know spice up
your life if you've been together a long
time and you watch it together and
you're exploring
different things watching together was
odd for me like it's mine because it's
it's a secret for you that's why it's
surprising it's mine it's my thing it's
weird for me to watch it with someone
it's like but i think it's don't you
think it's more healthy
yeah
in a relationship setting it it's it's
probably healthier to i don't actually
know i don't know i don't know i
i don't know i mean because if i'm with
my partner watching corn
someone's bound to be jealous man
somebody's bound to
somebody you somebody's bound to be
jealous i feel like maybe not everybody
maybe but somebody's going to feel you
know
yeah i could see i think there's there's
so there's something there that's a bit
that can go
wrong if you're both watching corn yeah
and this is why i say there's a time and
a place and there is a place for it
but like i agree with everyone else that
it's mostly negative but i do believe
that it
it has a it has its place one other
thing is if something's free
it's normally bad for you no if
something's free you're the product
and i agree with sarah i think the
homemade porn is just where it's at yeah
just yours yours you know
this has been the great area
this has been the grey area folks listen
thank you all for watching um
i've enjoyed this conversation i think
it was definitely needed
um
i thought i feel like we kind of
made pearl a little bit less innocent
today
there's a lot of terms that i i just
learned
um
dad please please don't watch this
episode
por favor um
i'm gonna read the last couple of super
chats